okay I think it's happening
and we're live at the West Palm Beach
Marriott do you want to mute the TV
or turn it off yeah should we turn it
off right there
let's turn it off
yeah West Palm Beach Hilton Room 217
because anybody wants to join there is a
do not disturb sign out there though so
maybe we should take that down
if you want people to join please
disturb
why does it look so blue
hello hello is the light blue
is this live is that where do you where
do you where can somebody watch that
YouTube
oh that's a YouTube chat yeah it's on my
YouTube personal page but you guys can
rip it and do whatever you want with it
well I don't know how to do that Hans
rip it
you show me how to rip it I'll show you
how to rip it in this skateboard
no I was hoping you could show me how to
shred it I can't shred it I can rip it
without shroud he never skateboarded
before no never done a single little
Ollie or whatever analy analy and gnarly
nollie analia you did a snorly last
night or you're snoring so loud it woke
everyone up
yeah William that was uh he wasn't
talking to me I oh
like I was talking about you and you're
snoring
yeah well
um you know it's just something I've had
to live with uh my poor wife I'm good
thank you my poor wife has uh had to
live with it we've had to live with it
for years now it's terrible have you
thought about getting a CPAP machine
what is that
what's going on with CPAP what's that
what's your dreams or something what is
CPAP do you know Hans Colonial
pap smear
Colonial Penn Amphitheater I have my
wife and I ever considered getting a
colonial pap smear I don't no I can't
say honestly that we ever have
collodial PID pap smear
well we all slept together last night
that was fun yeah we all slept in the
same room we got to know each other
um Ike's Norris
yeah that's I guess that's all we got to
know but that I that I snore what else
William
was laughing at you
I was not laughing how long did the
snoring go on before you had to maybe
five seconds okay yeah
the why are you making me feel so bad
about it if it was only five seconds
you're acting like I disrupted your
moment
cycle briefly humorous yeah it was funny
oh
okay yeah it was like really funny
about that hey I'm laughing now that's
yeah it was sweet that's pretty funny
so um yeah we we all spent the night
together we went on a little trolley
ride or like a little electric car ride
and we all got wet
sexually for what I was drenched
is kind of an uncomfortable ride
I feel like it could have been way
better if it was in the daytime or in
Sun sunny weather
but it's raining in uh wherever we are
reading in West Palm Beach
I can I kissed last night remember that
hunt yeah
they got it on tape they say they tape
out did they yeah
maybe you can rip that into something
good I'm gonna definitely have to rip
that and do something with that you
would I'm definitely going to have to
rip that and do something with that
okay Hans why did you bring us all
together here today yeah Hans it seemed
like there was something really pressing
on your mind so we all here today uh
this weekend at the West Palm Beach
Improv opening up for the great Tony
Hinchcliffe and I just wanted to
um get us all here together to sort of
talk about
the queen yeah I cannot believe she died
has it come out yet what happened to
somebody was she murdered seriously it
was like a math fight or something yeah
she was uh climbing down a storm drain
and some uh security guards saw her
and then uh Iranian uh Ninja killed the
security guard in the engaged in knife
fight with the queen you don't hear
enough about Iranian ninjas but they're
out there
fashions
I mean assassins
did you say hashish hashishins have you
ever smoked that stuff hashish
uh is that like uh whoa are you guys
smoking hashish
is that anything like hookah I've done a
hookah
you don't really know what it's like
opium
opium opium more like copium you guys
coping the Queen's death hard like a
bunch of cucks
so what is this I could what is this
we're smoking
uh I think you're smoking the end of it
I strike the end of it
uh this is a a grapefruit uh lemon zest
sort of uh Chinese herbal Delta eight
cousin derivative
ooh that is like a gas taste to it yeah
it's the uh it's whatever I just said it
was oh that tastes like gasoline
you ever do you like gasoline uh
it's a gasoline did you taste that no
the thing that tastes like gasoline
try the other one you might get a
headache now
oh my god oh gosh oh my God
should we do other drugs do you have any
do you have memes
yeah where's Mimi did she wake up today
oh my God I hope so
oh this tastes like Chama chamamine
dream I mean dream it all Tramadol isn't
that like the chemical when you eat
turkey
that's Ramen that's tryptophan
tryptophanes in Turkey
and I'm in your mom
you gotta stop that Hans you you came on
to my mom a month ago at one of the kill
Tonys and
she told me even texting her and it's
been a whole ordeal I mean she's a grown
woman
how did that end up with Ike's mom
it was uh I like Ike let's just say I
like Ike I'm not gonna call you stepdad
well you look like a future stepdad
I don't know how to take that you're
very young oh okay is that what that
means that's what that means
okay nice
future step down you don't see too many
like GQ list of top 10 future step dads
it's a you don't see enough of those
yeah someone's gotta get on that
that's what he has to
it's imperative
somebody has to
it's imperative
they really have to I mean they have to
should we do this
okay let us know how the volume is
because to me I feel like I'm a little
too quiet
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello
anyways just sound off in the comments
about the volume
so we got our first question step daddy
Hunt is this like a JRE podcast tryout
yeah it's my audition right this is like
a casting couch of sorts you guys
invited me here and said that I need to
give it my all is what you kept saying
and quotes you kept saying I needed to
give it my all and then you kept winking
at Hans and I was like I don't
I don't yeah Ike's about to get on the
Joe Rogan podcast I think yeah he is
trying whoever asked that you're correct
Ike is trying out I'm really trying
I've submitted at least four references
um a couple CVS
it's a process six interviews
six interviews up to this point yeah
yeah did you have to take a test where
they were like if an elk is 20 yards
away and you only have a bow and a
compound knife do you a
to a
uh I put no for that I don't a I don't
know if that's right uh the Proctor
didn't seem too pleased with that with
what I put but
no that's a great podcast we're just
trying to do our own little podcast here
some would say it arrivals Hotel cast
you know
we're rivals
yeah in the hotel but yeah we all slept
ended up in the same bed last night we
slept like head to foot foot to head
head to foot we were getting to know
each other
that way it's not weird
yeah not at all your feet kind of
smelled your feet smelled great yeah no
I was gonna say nice yeah I was gonna
ask if you use any kind of like scrub or
exfoliant or anything Biore highly
recommend the Biore it's a pomegranate
pomegranate Biore
can we scoot over a little bit so I'm
not so much in the table
I mean I don't mean to be a diva don't
try not I don't know if I can this is
kind of that chair is heavy he moved
that chair
hahaha
who moved this chair in the first place
are you impressed that's a heavy ass
chair dude I mean
I don't really
remember moving it that much
he more scooted it
scooted up
um
so what do you guys think about the
queen
really sad do a thumbs up in the chat if
you want to see us all make out
let's see some thumbs up in the chat if
you want to I'm gonna need to see like a
serious string of Thumbs Up from yeah we
need like at least ten thousand we need
to get like a streak going
yeah just we need yeah thumbs up emojis
or
what other kind of emojis would be you
said you liked the saluting one right
yeah do tin saluting emojis that will
make we'll start
slowly making out Hans are you cool with
that yeah
ten okay we need 10 Saluda mode just
podcast is now 30 bed
if we get five fairy emojis we'll take
our shirts off uh oh hold on we're
getting a couple thumbs up it wasn't in
a row though thumbs down okay all right
thumbs down equals three thumbs up so
whoever did that you're having me you're
trying to be [ __ ] funny but little
did you know it's actually three thumbs
up
okay we're getting Hans is uh
putting this Hans camera on a tripod on
a pizza box on a bed Hans ever those
ribs earlier they were sloppy yeah I've
never seen someone eat ribs so messy
you want to talk about my snoring I want
to talk about your rib hands your rib
mouth rib mouth everyone gets red mouth
what do you mean everybody gets rib
mouth when they eat ribs or just
generally that's it's like a symptom
it's like George or of a larger issue
similar to trench foot people were
eating ribs in World War One and the
trenches and they got rib mouth yeah
I got rid of us
I read that what was that magazine we
were looking at yesterday it was the
National Geographic no Ranger Rick they
were talking about it in Ranger wreck
also what was that other magazine
highlight highlight magazine yeah they
were talking about it in there seemed
like a very depressing uh you know stray
from their usual subject matter or they
normally just have like cute little
word searches and let's see some thumbs
up in the let's see some thumbs up in
the chat if you're subscribed to
Highlights magazine I have a buy uh what
is it bi-weekly membership yeah they
send one out twice a month
we're there four weeks in a month the
bi-weekly membership I pay for a
subscription and they give half of it to
lgbtq organizations what about the Plus
I don't know it's just the buy manual
thing I don't know I think if I did the
trans
uh it would be more more inclusive
I don't know I I might have to upgrade
is this better
it feels feels good I feel good
um so what do you guys think about the
uh
the the the the magazines the uh
National Geographic
the Hans you still have some of the ribs
I wonder if people can see can people
zoom in and clip this and rip this
because you do have flip it and rip it
clip it and rip it out like right here
remember this time stamp yeah what do
you mean right here yeah there's rib
stuff I mean the sauce that's not
normally on your face that's what we
mean
gingerly going at it you should be you
should lightly brush it up luckily it's
going from my chin onto my clothes
shouldn't those thumbs up uh translate
to something
people were thumbs up and we didn't do
anything
are they telling us they were thumbing
us let's thumb back
Thumbelina
Thumbelina
is that a musical yeah we're talking
about musicals earlier I didn't realize
you enjoyed what the mute you don't like
it Hans uh
Gravity from Wicked earlier we were
watching gravity oh that's true so I was
thinking gravity and they were like oh
look a musical head over here I do think
if comedy didn't work out for you though
that you could try your hand at Broadway
you had a beautiful voice Hans and then
you had a beautiful voice you think so I
think I try so much
[Music]
keep going
[Music]
from the musical yeah I think that's
from like Les Mis or something it's like
the act one closer
the music man that was a fun one I was
in a production of the music man in
middle school and I was kicked out for
anger management issues
well I swear to God if I if we knew that
you wouldn't have stayed in here last
night I was a little worried you might
try to strangle us in our sleep but you
didn't and then I started thinking hold
on actually am I going to strangle like
because of the snoring no not that I was
just thinking
like oh okay you wanted to be proactive
I didn't know if I was rubbing you the
wrong way or no stop the whole time I
was like I'm rubbing you does this feel
good or is it the wrong way or is this
the wrong way no it was nice
seriously it was nice
I stayed with us last night it was very
nice
stayed out talking about our favorite
musicals our hopes our dreams our fears
we got to know Mimi
yeah Mimi works at the I don't I
probably shouldn't say that she works at
the Buffalo Wild Wings in West Palm
Beach here a few minutes away me it was
her birthday it was her birthday already
days ago not specific because then they
could find her social security number
she had a bunch of pills in her purse
that's the funny thing is like girls are
always telling you when their birthday
is and it's like I could easily steal
your identity now yeah I know your
birthday girls are always telling me
their mother's maiden names and I'm like
I could steal your identity now yep
[ __ ] please
[ __ ] we know it's your birthday we also
know that the second digit in your
social security number is a five
so that's pretty much all you need one
digit in the social security number yep
yep that's like Domino's
fall
so oh my gosh does that mean somebody
gave you money yeah yeah that sounds
are we splitting that three ways or yeah
Jacob Jones how do you want that money
uh split dude yeah put it in the chat
how you want the money don't just give
us money yeah do you want like William
to get 20 cents and me to get five or
five dollars five cents oh well he
didn't even give five dollars how would
we get five yeah five dollars I mean no
offense Jacob but he didn't give five
dollars yeah Jacob we needed five bucks
dude we really needed five we're hungry
right now we haven't been able to eat
we've been literally trapped in this
[ __ ] hotel room for what a day now
what 16 hours almost 24. almost a full
day 324. yeah it's actually like 26
hours yeah and then Ike
joined us don't tell the Marriott
because we're not actually supposed to
have three guests in here yeah that's
gonna be a problem I know we should
probably shouldn't have said the
Marriott
that's gonna be a problem
when the you know when we came back and
the room was clean there was definitely
like you do you think they would tell
there was this project that your pillow
was willingness pillow which is a
hilarious mistake you got the oldest
pillowcase in the world
that was sweet though
how long have you had that pillowcase
um I think it's been uh hand-me-downs
since when the queen was born so it's
actually a fitting that I have this here
wow good job a day after she died day
after the anniversary you can weep into
your pillow
still smells like her
it does you want yeah you want to take a
whiff wherever it is where'd it go it's
all the way over there
where'd it go
where did it so
what did you guys think of this
crazy West Palm Beach area that we're in
right now kind of a lot of
a lot of old
little old white little old whites here
don't you think I
um of all the whites I've seen they have
been significantly older than most
people
there's not enough Starbucks or vape
stores
yeah that we need more we need more it's
like a giant caramel hey we got 45 DKK
is that uh
what's DKK is that some North Middle
Eastern currency Democratic corrupt
Korea oh my gosh no PR or what no PRK
dprk can someone donate like a Dogecoin
or like a half of a Litecoin or get a
quarter pounder with cheese who the [ __ ]
was that directed at well because you
said you were we were hungry we hadn't
eaten yeah we could split it we could
all split a quarter pounder with cheese
that's like what's a third of a quarter
[ __ ] do you know that Hans a third of a
quarter so that'd be one twelfth I I
could go for a 1 12 pound burger right
now me too that's how much that's how
much Cherokee I am
no you're not
you're Cherokee like really tiny
percentage do you believe that Hans yeah
we [ __ ] all of them are they [ __ ]
you guys [ __ ] each other I think
everyone is like this much Cherokee
we're all Cherokee
nobody's not Cherokee
yeah everybody's Cherokee
did you know that yeah I'm the one that
told you that I was Cherokee and you
were there I know I'm trying to play it
cool how Cherokee are you you don't want
to [ __ ] this is this is a good
sentence this is a good podcast segment
how Cherokee are you or what kind of
Cherokee are you that's so Cherokee
um
that would be a good show first up on
the show it's William William answer the
question probably a 16th I think a
grandparent was half
are you
I'm part OshKosh B'Gosh
what happened to that clothing brand
I had a good pair of things that
happened to the Mohicans
Daniel Day-Lewis bought them out
what a weirdo people don't talk about
Daniel Day Lewis enough what a total
[ __ ] weirdo is he I don't really know
that much about him what's weird you
didn't hear about what when he was in
last of the weekends
he bought like a mall
really yeah where they were filming it
just they filmed he now he just lost the
Mohicans in a mall yeah yeah it's a lot
of CGI yeah he bought that mall
remember the mall scene
is it still a functioning what has
happened to my treasured Homeland
good Native American acts thank you
brother
thank you brother thank you brother Big
Ups to you them that's my uh what's
happening to my beautiful Homeland
complete an axon right big oops
what was the part after Big Ups the Big
Ups to udem yeah to you them
fine-tuning here okay
yeah bumbaclot what does that mean it
means like no worries for the rest of
for your day rest of your days
it's like how red band always hey what
does that mean it means no worries
what's your favorite
Jackson Five song
[Music]
um what is that though thing Michael
Jackson was in yeah
is that what they were called two three
yeah wonder wall
that's your favorite Jackson Five yeah
it's kind of a weird
speaking of Wonderwall how about that
Thunder call close call oh [ __ ]
oh no oh no it died
we can fix this
Hans is currently fake you should see
all of the people watching us can't see
but there is literally a sea of cordage
behind can they still hear us yeah okay
it's just the light that's out oh behind
the laptop there's a sea of
chords yeah it's a lot of chords you're
kind of like uh Tangled Up over there
Hans oh look it's better mood lighting
though baby you like it especially if
the making out happens anytime soon it
looks like we're in like a old Grandma's
it's like sepia town it's like when the
70s
sepia what is that it's like a sepia is
that how it's pronounced yeah it's like
a color filter that they have on like
Instagram and [ __ ] CPI CPI
sepio
sepia
sepia
sapodilla what's your favorite font
right now it's anorem
um but I like Comic Sans is a classic
you know you guys want to insert an ad
right here yeah can we do that how do
you do that can I can I choose what I'm
doing an ad for that
we just inserted an ad sorry guys
is are they is it playing an ad now is
that how that works or what does that
mean
yeah they played an ad for all the
people wow so what did you just make
five thousand dollars or something
let's do an ad for each one yeah let's
do it three ads for three of us there
you go coming up I don't even know what
that means do it when you say that yeah
do you know the company
what you're advertising like what if
you're advertising some incredibly
unethical terrible thing that next up is
a company you should definitely put your
money into Ranger Rick
this is your ad break oh no don't cue
that up
I'm shuttering to think of what the ad
is going to be this is why you got
Adblock look at the ad block it's a life
changer
what is the ad All Those ads on YouTube
are weird because I've been watching
tons of Judge Milian do you like her is
she around here can she come to the show
tonight baby it's called Judge Marilyn
Milian she's a fan of com you don't know
Judge Marilyn Milian from The People's
Court I mean maybe you're kidding maybe
I know the face but I don't know the
name you don't watch The People's Court
um I just watched Judge Jerry
Judge Jerry yeah oh yeah that's a real
show he has his own judging show now
that just judge Steve or something I
think Steve Harvey has his own one too
would you just knock over a bowl of
Skittles it sounded like what was in the
bowl what was that oh it was my gum you
can have some if you want
um yeah I could put a piece of gum in
his mouth right before we all went to
sleep last night what happened with that
gum I threw it out eventually we stayed
up okay we went to sleep and then stayed
up talking for like an hour or so I
didn't choke on it or anything
I was fine just to be clear
okay good I'm glad you were all right I
was thinking we'd wake up and it'd be
like in the back of your hair you'd have
to weaken it burning me at the show
tonight
what does that mean we bring you up and
my dead body and your you and Hans are
puppeteering it so that way Tony doesn't
catch wise of what's going on
oh gosh
do you think he could do it
could we hold him up Hans
we could do it yeah I'm totally down if
you need us to well we do have two shows
going on tonight so maybe if you need us
to maybe one of them if I die yeah if I
die something happened between now and
then I really appreciate that that means
a lot can we Hans let's do it yeah
something happens between now and then
we can all right you keep saying it and
it's making me feel a little unsettled
like something's going to happen now no
no just if something I see twinkle in
Han's eye and I don't like it I lost my
little fuzzy thing
Hans where did it go was it when you
tripped and fell over a bunch of [ __ ]
over there yeah
it's got rib all over it now oh no
no it doesn't you cleaned it off thanks
is it off your pants you did when you
dropped your rib earlier was it on your
pants or on the chair it was on the
pants Oh no these pants are getting
pretty dirty I might have to return them
to Amazon
what you just get some stains on them
and then returns and they have like a
rib policy do they allow for that you
don't think there's someone in some
Warehouse somewhere like
huh
wow that's always eating is so wontonly
like it was wonton soup
that was a good and what you won your
game yeah playing on my Katan with the
largest army
One kitten I actually just uh passed 1
billion balloons popped on my balloons
tower defense six
I'm not kidding one million no one
billion
I think I want to post a picture because
I swear to God people I have impressed
it's an insane amount of balloons I
gotta see that you gotta pull that that
is insane I haven't played that game in
so long oh it's the best gay is it the
balloons one the balloons tower defense
oh I recognize that logo yeah oh it's
the best I'm totally addicted to it
balloons tower defense six here you'll
take a look at this this is very
impressive for those who don't know
balloon stay or defense you wish you
could see this public stats how many
balloons uh public stats total pop count
oh my God 1 billion 23 million 555
995 balloons take a look on confirm
billion repeat the number that's a lot
of time there's two numbers here though
total cash generated underwear which is
an impressive amount 1 billion 23
million 555 995 balloons pop I wasn't
making it up that's how many balloons I
popped if anybody wanna wants to come at
me I was not good at it more like
eventually once you do enough stuff to
it it's just like chaotic to even look
at like the whole screen is just
balloons popping and [ __ ] going on yeah
but you have to know how to play whoa
whoa switch back to that She-Hulk
lighting the green one yeah that was fun
that was cool
hell yeah can you twerk maybe just like
She-Hulk twerk you didn't see that no
she hurt She-Hulk was I mean it's a show
right now and it came under Fire weren't
people mad about it there's a scene
where she I guess she's a lawyer and
she's representing Megan the stallion
and uh as you do the two of them are
just twerking together in the office
it's a great scene it's awesome I don't
get it I think it's fun
so odds what are you doing with that I'm
trying to match the you know the Yelp
sepia tone color
of the whatever that is that looks good
and now we're all matching color wise
so there's it's not white and that's
brown or whatever yellow
raw matching I can't believe you did
that I don't know how you only took like
40 minutes into this for it to finally
get the perfect light a little by little
every day
what is that from that Musical
yeah that's uh
Jesus is loving me oh yes he's loving me
keep going little by little every day
I don't think that's the right song no
you guys you guys why is Jesus loving me
only little by little yeah he loves you
a lot Hans I agree very much don't be so
modest huh
loving me oh yes he's loved me my Jesus
is that really from Little Shop of
Horrors yeah yeah yeah you don't know
that song I didn't know it had uh had
Christian undertones to us the whole
second act of Jesus is what saves them
from the plant
what is the plant's name Seymour
uh no Seymour is the guy who feeds him
the plants name too
Audrey too yeah well the main uh uh
woman in the show her name is Audrey and
so the plane's name is Audrey too
hello Chris
Hillcrest game says my pop count is 30
million and I feel like I've played too
much
so what are you getting at Hillcrest I'm
not blocking over a billion dogs that
means you're like three and a half times
sadder than there ten times actually
yeah three and a half isn't it wouldn't
it be more than that a thousand times a
thousand times six I'm pretty sure it's
three and a half times three and a half
tons okay
I want a million
three yeah I have a billion look I was
just a thousand times I was trying to
undersell how sad you should feel if you
want to feel as sad as you should sure
yeah it's a thousand times sadder
I'm a thousand times more sad than that
guy a guy who did himself after gaming
gamer guy well it should be that much
more impressive
I just hope you all are impressed with
it is it more than just a time thing you
actually have skill to it
I do the same setup for every single
thing so it's almost like I'm a crazy
person you figured out what works I
think that's great yeah now are there
any like I still find something that
works achievements left to unlock or
levels too there's a lot of achievements
yeah I have I have a bunch of monkeys I
still need to unlock that
how does popping balloons help with
monkey release well I mean we're
currently in a collection event so I've
been playing pretty hard during the
collection event is this uh app is that
like yeah it's similar
collection event with Toyota
function
well it ends with an A so it's so easy
to ass on
I prefer Honda days you do yeah
craze
Hyundai craze Honda days whatever
happened to Hyundai Elantras like you're
on them for a while and now you're sort
of like
you know I really likely not allowed to
be near them anymore right literally I
flipped one too many yep I got to 15
Hyundai you were trying to go for the
same town
there was a point where you had the same
total of balloons popped that you had
Hyundai Elantras flipped and you were
trying to keep that number neck and neck
right I had to but I had to stop I got
blisters on my fingers a lot of the
times those cars if they just stop
they're really hot underneath the chest
it's much easier to pop some balloons on
your [ __ ] little phone than it is to
actually get out there on the street
flip a car yeah my little phone it's
easier what your little phone
balloons
my point is
I bought a billion balloons if you flip
the billion Hyundai's that's like can
you say that four more days
Sunday I just like where is that from
South Korea it does yeah
and I was like what are you doing dude
it's like your mom dude that's
incredible
would you be mad at me yeah but I
wouldn't necessarily Target your mom
well no yeah it wouldn't be anything
personal like your mom's gonna get
targeted but it's not because she's your
mom it's because it's just fair and
equal treatment welcome to America [ __ ]
yeah welcome to America you're talking
all right good luck trying to flip your
car back over it's gonna be on the roof
that's a heavy ass it's way harder than
the other way around it's totally more
difficult yeah let's just get it rocking
true and then you see those videos of
like uh you know like when a big sports
team and a city wins and then everyone's
rocking [ __ ] you know yeah it looks fun
yeah I love to do that let's just do it
tonight let's start it go rock a car in
West Palm Beach yeah if you've got a car
in West Palm Beach say you don't mind us
rocking and flipping yeah let us know
please let us know yeah if you happen to
live at West Palm Beach you have a car a
Hyundai we can flip over and you want to
watch let us know we're not going to
flip it back over though so
just be yeah you're on your own once
it's done once the damage is done the
damage is done
anything his watch just walk away fade
off into the distance and like
and it's hard renting out one of those
do y'all remember the Brave Little
Toaster the big magnet thing it was a
machine magnet at like the junkyard you
need one of those to flip it back over
how does it do it
yeah you connect it and then you do it
like you need to I know it can be kind
of hard because sometimes if you drop it
it just lands on them right back there
when that happens I'm like ah not again
I know the person operating it has to be
moving the arm you've probably seen a
lot you gotta swing it yeah you have to
swing after math of your wake right
oh yeah yeah I've seen tons
awful they're giant machines
they're huge it's it's impressive to
watch
huge machinery
do you want to get closer to William
would you allow me
yeah if you want to I was wondering why
you were over there yeah right arm is
out of this earlier Hans told me to
scoot over now I've scooted too far I
don't know what you want from me I just
want to make the perfect podcast and I'm
getting [ __ ] on from all sides gamer guy
you gamer Guy Gamer guy was making fun
of William oh oh yeah dude a million
[ __ ] balloons come at me after 500
500 million is that a billion that's
like three and a half times less than
one what's a billion how many millions
300 Millions 100
it's a thousand Millions a thousand
millions or a billion oh my God you look
like his pet
himself
that in cell is that what you said yeah
okay sorry I'm married somebody called
us gay on there
all three of us are just you and me and
anyone Cream City
oh no
not Cream City
it
Cream City take that back
yeah Cream City come on man I mean I
know we're trying to have fun here but
that really honestly kind of took the
wind out of my sails
yeah Cream City we're trying to have a
good time in this Marriott and you're
[ __ ] I didn't think I was doing
anything gay
yeah what's your story Cream City why
are you even calling people hey what's
going on yeah what's even going on
just says I'm pooping now
impression lol
you [ __ ] said that what idiot said
that Hans can you do uh
scuzzy
who the [ __ ] in that
can you not you do
I can't do that right now I can't do
that on the spot yeah
just took away the Magic by doing that
now you really expect me to try to
Huntress I can't yeah you're trying to
[ __ ] you're setting me up for disaster
why are you telling I can't do that
after Hans [ __ ] does it
to the fake William I come on who the
[ __ ] said that I don't have that I don't
have that much of a Southern accent so
doing an impression who the [ __ ] said
that
so what do you guys think about like
the uh
that we're right next to Mar-A-Lago
yeah where is it whoa
that really accentuates how bald I am
it's quite cinematic really anybody
knows anything about cinematic lighting
check out the liminal lines on Williams
it's not funny
what are liminal lines it's like a
hallway I think it means like oh yeah
liminal spaces what is it's like creepy
it's like a place you don't want to be
I think it means Lines no I think it's
just a place you don't want to be like
in the checkout line at a grocery store
in the middle space you don't like
grocery stores God I'm in the gas
chamber again that's a liminal space the
Holocaust was full of liminal spaces
that's why there's so many good
directors and Holocaust movies came out
of the Holocaust
oh did they I mean movies I guess not
directors Steven Spielberg yeah he was
in the Holocaust he was a great director
for it George Lucas we wouldn't have uh
Star Wars without Hitler
Martin Scorsese was a guard
yeah yeah
it's weird that they still let him
direct he just did the Irish man or
whatever yeah it seems like you go to
jail for that oh man
yeah and he's doing the Irish man he was
a [ __ ] Garden out there let him do
the Irish man I mean what is going on
what's the state of affairs in America
right now where Martin Scorsese can make
the Irishman when he was
everybody knows he was a guard Sophia
Coppola I'm pretty sure was like pulling
gold out of people's mouths and selling
it you know those doctors that did that
this one is cool
because she was a baby she was a child
doctor
they let her experiment Francis Ford her
dad was uh
like Dr Doogie Hauser isn't Dr Doogie
Hauser based off of that's my favorite
director
oh you like his stuff yeah he's really
NPH
who Neil Patrick no I'm talking about
someone else I think his name is he was
the world's youngest doctor yeah after
uh Sophia Coppola yeah Doogie Howser I
wonder youngest dog there second oldest
doctor on the books I think he's gay now
I know I heard that yeah I wonder if
that has something to do with being a
doctor so young he's just I think so I
just had too many naked butts
you know if you see too many naked men
you just turn gay
it's a numbers game at that point it's
bound to happen it's a numbers game
yes it's just like Balloon Tower Defense
it is a number there's a numbers game
literally you don't get to a billion
pops without playing for
28 days that's how much time I have on
it 28 Days full days
not at the same time right but just like
can accrued compounded over time I'm
kidding it doesn't say the amount of
time you've been on it and I'm glad
because I think you would be more than
20. I don't know you can see in your
settings
how much time are you spend on the app
yeah yeah there's a there's a whole time
there's a setting and uh I would say it
tells you you're talking together 30
days
um how do you get to it gotta guess
before we find out
let me type in usage [ __ ] I'm trying to
remember you can definitely
yeah today time screen's today is that
only today though oh wait
oh you haven't oh it's not on okay it's
not activated well I don't want it
activated all right okay
okay like if you go on I don't know you
can see that I'm on
um xhamster.com for like seven hours a
day what is that porn
um you looking at porn and uh
so yeah xHamster seven hours a day bible
app that's four hours a day except porn
the Bible app no no it's not they do
have some really steamy scenes though
you should put a porn image and a Bible
caption
it could be like the Delilah
is Delilah a character yeah she's the
one that temps Sampson into cutting his
hair
oh that's her [ __ ] yeah
like Riley Reed or someone from like a
scene somewhere yeah nice okay how'd she
trick him
people don't talk about that enough how
did she there's a lot of trigger in the
Bible I can't think of her name but the
one daughter early on in the first
couple chapters who turned a lot drunk
father into [ __ ] her oh Noah I don't
think it was wasn't no yeah was it yeah
Noah's daughter Noah's daughter [ __ ]
Noah wasn't it like two daughters that
would have been like [ __ ] their dad come
let us make love with our fathers so we
can procreate my favorite part of the
Bible is the begot part
so it would be like you know William and
Ike but got Hans
that's not how it works it's the hottest
part it's a sex set in Florida by far
and there's at least seven pages where
it's just
like so you're just reading that and
thinking oh they had sex oh yeah well
the funny thing is there's a genealogy
in Matthew and there's a genealogy in
Mark and they don't line up it's like
different names and they have different
numbers of people so there's like when I
read Harry Potter
holes with Hermione
what's one plot hole with Hermione
um you know I JK spent a grueling amount
of time working in this uh you guys ever
read Harry Potter or see Harry Potter
you guys know Harry Potter Harry Potter
more like
fairy water
yeah I mean I don't know I don't watch
that [ __ ] well she uses a Time Turner in
one of the books or movies it's a time
travel necklace that allows her to take
multiple classes at the same time yeah
and I feel like they could have gone
more into how that affects her menstrual
cycles but they didn't they didn't at
all not like like literally zero percent
of the book is on that and I think that
at least four chapters should have been
dedicated to the plot hole absolute plot
hole in my in my mind that's what they
could did you know that Hans they called
that a plot hole yeah
when they didn't get into the man did
y'all see The Da Vinci Code a lot lot's
daughter
lot's daughter yeah I don't think that
was on Harry Potter
is he the guy that created those spaces
like in between buildings
yeah it's like where you go got their
father drunk my father to drink wine
that night also and the younger daughter
went in and slept with him he was not
aware of it when she laid out she got a
so both of us thought of eating pregnant
by their father
hey follow the Bible if the Bible says
it's okay you can do it
yeah follow the New Testament Hans not
the Old Testament we're not in Israel
well it's the second best are you Jewish
I
why do you ask
just from Context Clues from everything
we were talking about last night
what were we talking about that sparked
that in you menorah's
I have a deep interest in menorahs it's
a vested interest I collect them you
like eBay for your little yeah my little
shirt your little shirts and I like them
for my little menorahs okay well I'm
sorry I tried to use contacts quiz I was
trying to fill in my glasses Clues isn't
that what they're called contact clues
contact list contacts through
astigmatism I can't find uh your glasses
right I'm gonna use contacts clues you
gotta have proper syntax
but you have to have right syntax
write syntax
now I dodged my syntaxes this year
did you yeah yeah how are you able to
aren't you worried about the IRS yeah
the sin RS I've been thinking about it
this whole [ __ ] podcast I know you
guys are laughing and having fun but I
cannot stop thinking about the i r s
i r
in trouble
IR Stein you the guy that wrote the
books
RL Stein you wanna
you want to get a little further away
from William right now would you allow
me
it looks like you're literally about to
sit on his lap right now okay so you
want to go further away then you want me
to scoot closer then further away I'm
getting [ __ ] on from all sides you and
gamer guy and you and camera guy yeah I
can't get over what gamer guy was saying
I'm still pretty pissed about it like he
was coming at you
sometimes sadder than it sounds like a
lot of honestly [ __ ] petty [ __ ]
from someone who isn't man enough to get
to as many balloons popped as you and he
wants to [ __ ] dampen Your Shine yeah
dude I've popped a billion balloons
that's a [ __ ] yeah this podcast really
needed a table with a bunch of [ __ ] so
that's what this [ __ ] podcast was
missing I've been thinking that this
whole time
space
limit all spaces but I really want to be
here
it's not a little space and now I'm glad
you ended up making it in here though I
remember I jokingly said what did I say
to you Hans I was like where's I gonna
stay or something and then
hunt said oh yeah it's fine come over
and I was thinking okay this is gonna
work and then it and then it worked and
then you started snoring stuff twerking
and then they yeah it stopped working
you know you snort too but it's like the
most soft delicate snore I've ever heard
are you serious I'm being dead serious
because I woke up a couple times
um and I was just lying awake and
thinking about the IRS and yeah yeah uh
but I could hear you in the background
going like
really I recorded it
no you didn't yeah him snoring yeah
is that me or him no that's you okay
that's so funny you recorded that Hans I
know it really you stopped it ended up
being fine that's so funny you recorded
that though
I was horrified I was like how am I
gonna be able to sleep
I switched to my side and it was fine it
ended up working out for everyone this
is later on in the night
yeah
it sounds different it's a different
type of snore that's the side snore yes
at the side look if you guys want to
kick me out of the hotel room tonight
I'll find another person's floor to
sleep on it's fine dude just go up there
and beg
it could be like a front desk
six minute infomercial
no it's fine Ike that's so funny you
recorded that though Hans I did it I
just Googled snoring on YouTube
I was gonna be a little
what a great time we just had
uh uh that's funny yeah no yours was
definitely a lot more delicate it was
like
well yeah I have to sleep on my side if
I sleep on my back it'll I'll stop
breathing yeah you were saying you get
sleep paralysis you ever get that yeah I
hate that yeah it's awful does it happen
when you sleep on your back no I just
powered through it
wait you wake yourself up yeah I'm just
like sometimes I can wake myself up and
it's like The Kill Bill thing where
she's like okay move your toe but with
me it'll always be my hand I'm like okay
move your handle and sometimes and if I
can do that I can kind of get out of it
I'm not kidding it's like nightmarish
that's why I sleep on my stomach
I can't deal with that
yeah dude
you're lucky you've never had it I just
feel so awful I feel like I've spent so
much time judging you and ridiculing you
and I've never known what you were going
through
yeah well I'm glad you know now I never
took a moment to walk in William was
like hey I might freak out and start
yelling in the middle of the night so
just wake me up I kind of wish that it
happened so it wouldn't it would have
made my snoring look not as bad
one of those dreams luckily I didn't
have a dream of you killing me one of my
buddies visited me in Austin and he just
was totally out of it he had gotten the
electro shock therapy
because he was having problems I think
he's better now
but he came without a bag or anything to
visit me in Austin and the whole thing
scared me and I had a dream that night
that he kicked in the door and murdered
me it was scary it was so scary
unoffended that you thought that about
him and would think he wouldn't see this
I would guess he used to do a lot of
cocaine with him it was always fun
it's a lot of fun what was so fun about
it I don't know just listening to
he had a wonderful Star Wars album and
we'd listen to that and like that
yeah it was on the whole album and I
would pee in his sink and he wouldn't
like that did you all realize I peed in
the sinker
that's our emergency water supply yeah I
noticed there was water in there y'all
didn't notice it was a different color
I've just been laughing
I thought that was the fish oil
no that's TT oh my gosh we have to
unstop the water stopper we have to let
the water go down the drain yeah
we were just bathing in it
you were bathing in the sink yeah like a
little baby I was wondering why it's so
[ __ ] wet on the ground I was like
what is good that's right
like giggling and I didn't realize it
was Hans bathing himself in the sink
like a little child yeah I was playing
with myself wow no but uh it sounded
like you were having fun we have like a
toilet and a shower and we're you just
using the sink for both things it's like
we need to start using the proper
bathroom appliances I know I'll stop
I'll start [ __ ] in the shower or
wait what sorry what are you telling us
to do I'll start
brushing my teeth over the toilet
that doesn't seem so bad no as long as
you don't that's what the days are for
the toilet
yeah the days you don't need a cup they
should install that like a little water
jet so you can just rinse your mouth
right
I have in the dentist you just pick it
up or put it down Dennis I meant more
suicide than any professional profession
I thought veterinarians did no I I had
heard the veterans veterans I also heard
that Walmart yeah
now Walmart you do a push-up guys or
something we're seat checkers
every time you do a push-up event that's
why I haven't done a pleasure so
veterans keep dying
it's something like that Williams killed
so many veterans these days or when we
were like if there's an earthquake you
got to get under a door frame right yeah
why is that I thought the whole building
comes down if there's an earthquake uh
earthquakes have deep respect for door
frames is that what it does just because
there's nothing that's gonna crash down
on you
there's a door frame that's strong
they should make the whole house out of
the door frame material yeah why are
they saving it it's like you're making a
nuclear bunker where only like this much
square footage is like resistant to
anything and the rest is all a glass
Dome what's the point it's like the
black box in an airplane yeah exactly
they should make the whole airplane out
of the Black Box I would love to ride or
out of a door frame that would be so
cool yeah airplane out of a door frame
yeah it could just be holes
it's a little windy but it's safe
it's really windy
why don't they make black boxes out of
door frame yeah I don't think
or why don't they make houses out of
black boxes
well yeah like when the house burns down
you can like go listen to everything
that was being said
isn't that what a black box is yeah wait
if what if like you know the whole oh I
guess if you're making the whole house
out of black box it wouldn't work but
like you know in a plane if a plane goes
down the Black Box survives you can kind
of play back and be like oh what were
they all talking about
what are y'all talking about just
general summary just random days what
were they talking about on the plane
before it crashed
because they have like recordings and
stuff right yeah I think yeah it's a
black box
it's like uh black [ __ ] what do you
mean African-American vagina it's the
only thing that will survive
when everything else in the world is
crashed and burned you gotta listen to a
black woman's uh oh honey you ain't
listening to my [ __ ]
not for that amount of money
that sounds more like a Mohican woman
than a black woman
anyways
um yeah if you're in an earthquake you
gotta get under a door frame and play
dead
but if it's a cougar then you gotta get
into my dog is super ready for
earthquakes
constantly playing dead is he yeah is he
doing okay he's earthquake prepping
okay and then a tornado get in the
bathtub yeah and appear larger than you
are yeah look larger than you are a good
like a towel over you in the bathtub if
there's just about to lay this and if
you're menstruating the tornado will
smell it yeah yeah if you're menstruate
if your wife is menstruating it's gonna
come to your house
doesn't matter what it's on if it smells
any kind of menstruation it's coming
right [ __ ] for you yeah and make sure
to put your food in a tree yeah put your
food in it it's extra sack hanging up in
a tree and put your wife there hang your
wife up in a tree unless she's a has a
black box in which case don't do that
because then you might be aggressive for
a hate crime
that's what they say
that's I'm taking a mental note right
now just to make sure I don't do that
okay I gotta go TG I'm gonna go will you
leave some in the sink again I'm getting
thirsty will people be able to hear me
teach you on the oh yeah right you could
hear that before right you might want to
turn your mic off
unless we just want to sit here on
interrupted and listen to him pee
in my cup God oh my God it's not turning
this mic off going on out there I don't
have any idea until like a giant a
disaster I'm trying to [ __ ] penis oh
my God you're peeing into the mic you
[ __ ] psycho
it doesn't sound like a healthy we're
doing why did I have to [ __ ] he
doesn't know how to turn it off he's
gonna do this I swear I don't know
such a big mistake and Mike was snoring
all night and I can't even be anymore
do you hear that and then I don't even
know how to tell Hans what's going on
oh my God that sounds horrible
acoustically
he's enjoying himself this is a long
time
are you okay you're doing it all on sync
right are you yeah I'm fine
I think you're losing too much water
losing viewers gamer guy is three I
can't hear you walk
oh my God that's disgusting our people
what do people think dude that was a
long P
what are you cutting weight for the UFC
huh are you trying to cut weight right
now and fight comes out to Maya
UFC fighters wish they had the peace
stream that William does
sounded powerful
sounded intimidating if I heard that I
wouldn't want to fight him that was a
growth I did hear it and I don't want to
fight him
did you hear them oh yeah I could hear
it I just washed my hands in there I
didn't that's good audience hear that
yeah
turtleneck or something
I know that's the bad part about these
vintage shirts I get on eBay all the
necks are too tight
it says a multi-room podcast that is
pretty extraordinary
it's like the the thing you were showing
us so what do you guys think about uh
should we try to call someone
oh yeah
do you have like um tell Tony to come
down here oh yeah you tell him
I'm not telling him anything
yeah that was a long P I literally peed
three minutes the other night when I got
back to my apartment because I drink all
those soda Waters I'm not even kidding
it was three minutes I don't know how
all of that was inside of me that's
pretty extraordinary
yeah three minute I feel like I should
be on my phone too no don't get on your
phone oh my God
um you guys think that uh
the tonight's show is gonna be great
The Tonight Show the time I haven't
watched it in a while I think they put
on a good production every day or every
week or however I can't wait dude that
crowd yesterday wasn't my favorite but
tonight it's gonna be great
yeah tonight should be good last night
seemed a little weird eye on is I felt
good about last night luckily I always
get worried about doing over
of my life
that was life-changing
that crowd was dumb as [ __ ]
stop saying that Hans what about
wonderful about it and then you keep on
saying oh they were so dumb and I'm like
oh my God
William and I were in The Green Room
like wow what a show well this is so fun
and no it's just it's raining on My
Parade it's been raining on My Parade
it's just like sort of like short
attention span theater
okay
yeah talky yeah
walking there is one guy in the front
row on his phone yeah he was very rude
yeah
so maybe he was looking up your net
worth or something
those things are those accurate like
sometimes when I watch a movie I see
like uh you know a [ __ ] like Denzel
Washington and I gotta look up his
Wikipedia where is he from what's his
net worth maybe that's what they were
doing with you
ever stop to think about that
I should have hit on his girlfriend in
front of him because he was on his phone
you snooze you lose oh yeah you had kids
you snooze you lose in the sense that if
you're not constantly hitting on your
own girlfriend Hans came is going to
come in and do it exactly okay
if you're not shedding get off the pot
I mean if people like that need to be
taught a lesson and if I have to [ __ ]
his girlfriend to teach him that lesson
then I'm down
that's what needs to be done
but uh yeah I mean he was uh weird
um I don't know how you know he has kids
did you talk to him no tourney was
talking to him at one point I think he
said he had kids was he like annoying
yeah nobody was answering Tony last
night that was funny remember yeah he's
like I shouldn't say it's like that's
great no one in this room has a job they
can say
um yeah that audience was uh gay but
tonight's show is gonna be great
way better than last night which sucks
no it didn't suck I was just kidding
yeah I think last night was probably my
best performance and I'm thinking oh God
I'm not gonna be able to top that and
there's four more shows so I'm horrified
a little bit
you're gonna be great I'm just gonna
only go down from last night bro you're
gonna be great
it's only downhill from there no no
uphill no but it's downhill better
downhill's easier downhill is easier
but it doesn't look that good uphill
sounds optimistic
everything looks uphill from here that
sounds horrible that sounds like a lot
more work although uphill battle
it's all up oh from here but if you take
the high road versus the low
huh
if there's a bird in your hand
let's do the math two birds equals one
stone
one stone one stone is like three and a
half Birds
or the stones throw away
it's close so two birds equals it's
close
throwing two birds
throwing two birds is further because
birds can fly
but it's not very true that you can get
a rock
hit the like button please
um
yarn she's supposed to say that yes I
supposed to say that why am I supposed
to say that and hit subscribe and oh
yeah be sure to hit smash that subscribe
button and drop kick the like button and
drop go ahead and
go ahead and um throat [ __ ] the comment
section and share on Twitter yeah you
know be sure to share on Twitter though
after you've throat [ __ ] the comments
incestuously share this on Twitter
and skull [ __ ] the
uh uh Subs uh we already did the RSS
feed okay that's fine yeah how was the
RSS beat on this is the RSS feedback the
signal is strong I'm always worried the
RSS is like four bars of RSS right now
do you yeah is that good yeah is that
why your phone is so hot right now I
feel the heat coming from your
headphones it's emanating yeah this is
actually being live streamed to the
International Space Station
really they're watching it up there
right now yeah they they're watching
everything now with that new telescope
of theirs God I hope they're not
watching gravity
watch Gravity if you're up in space and
everyone George Clooney was like pulling
her
into space for some reason and then he
she cuts or he he lets go and then she
magically bounces back the other way and
then he still won't stop [ __ ] talking
to her for like 20 minutes he's like
shut up dumbass but it's I'm thinking
like I mean maybe NASA walkie-talkies
are better but when I have a normal
Earth walkie-talkie if I get 10 feet
away from someone you're not gonna hear
me anymore why doesn't he do one of
these Maneuvers back to the spaceship
yeah
doggy paddle back to her
it's for people just learning how to
swim doggy paddle yeah Ike I would have
came I would have cannonballed my way
right back onto that space station not
even in Canada not a can do you know how
to do a Canon opener isn't that just
it's a can of all the leg is out did you
know that on you can opener
that I mean it doesn't can you do a game
I could literally do it right now it
doesn't seem can you can now imagine me
in the air going into a pool and you
have to do your one leg up like a
cannonball
oh okay so then yeah well I can't do it
standing yeah can opener it's like a
cannonball but one leg is out I don't
get why that's called a can opener
you didn't know that though no yeah it's
a can opener
I thought that was a pistol squat
that's not a pistol squat
I taught you what a Scorpion Kick was
yeah the most useless kick in the world
hey just in case someone is like staring
at the back of your head from an inch
away
you can hit them with the head scorpion
scorpion kick or what if like someone
was like grabbing me and they grabbed me
by the arms and I was subdued and I was
like oh [ __ ] I can't I can't break I
can't break out when I [ __ ] and kick
their head and they weren't directly
behind you so you just kicked their
shins really hard
but that doesn't even look as cool are
they off to the side just hanging on to
like sideways
yeah I mean what's going on how many
fights are you in dude
I'm not allowed to talk about it in any
kind of public forum is this your move
you're actually homeless and you just
sleep on
comedian floors yeah that's absolutely
it you're hopping from Comedy Club the
30th one in the last two months
yeah it's been a real ride real roller
coaster two days
two days in the hotel here for two more
nights
please
please sleep on your side today good
night
I'll sleep in my car if it's such an
issue oh you're not gonna sleep a lot in
my car it sounds concerning don't sleep
in your car it sounds like it's hard to
breathe
and you're just muscling through it
it feels great that's so funny I believe
that you really did record I exploring
less I totally believe it to anyone
because Google's snoring because nobody
really knows what they sound like when
they snore
yeah I don't think people realize what
they could you do you realize you're
snoring
I know that I snore
who knows
am I present in my dream state and I'm
like yeah I'm definitely we were we were
yelling at [ __ ] everyone well I
definitely heard you go Ike Ike I I
heard on your side and we knew that you
were awake because of snowing's not but
you didn't say anything you were just
laying there like what's going on I was
disoriented I was [ __ ] disoriented we
had to be like stop snoring it was so
dark in here with these blackout
curtains it was pitch black dark in here
I know that's the best way to sleep
yeah I love it
but yeah you were like when you first
woke up you were like
is there someone in there like what were
you thinking right did you think that
there was like a fire or no no I kind of
had a feeling I went as I went to sleep
after you apologized in advance for the
screening that might happen I kind of
thought oh maybe I should apologize in
advance for the snoring that might
happen and I kind of thought oh that's
definitely gonna happen and it did but
it was all right it ended quit as just
as quickly as it started I don't know it
seems to be a big hot topic on this
podcast like 40 of the name of the
podcast is the Ike's Norris podcast
again I don't think we've spent nearly
enough time talking about your rib hands
your rib mouth your red pants
but my snoring oh God God forbid
it's just funny man it was so loud for
like five minutes how am I supposed to
say Tim and I were just looking at each
other like can you believe this yeah
my [ __ ] what is going on
I'm trying to count to ten right now
okay Mike's mad at us like we're kidding
like we're kidding dude five seven and
get to 10. it's gonna kick us out of our
beds I felt so bad sleeping in a bed I
was just rolling around with all that
you guys sounded really comfy
Willow we each gave you a pillow every
time you said anything I was just like
oh they sound so rested you could lay on
all the pillows like just get like four
pillows what if I like laid between the
ends of your two beds like my feet what
would be the point of that I like this
because you're far away from me I don't
have to think about you
foreign
yeah yeah it's a good arrangement
it does I like not being thought about
we should just sleep under the table
would that give you a sense of comfort
it would make me feel like I'm doing
like a tornado drill in school but yeah
if there was a shooting and a guy comes
in here he would shoot at the beds for
sure but he would definitely miss you
he'd be like there can't be a third
person in here
surely there can't be
sleeping in the corner while these two
sleep comfortably yeah I killed them but
they're still snoring that's weird
we're at who are you texting none of
your business dude
know your business is it your agent no
are you texting your agent again are you
trying to get a hotel room by yourself
yeah they just cast me and uh they're
coming out the second version of the
music bin
they've been like the first movie
you know they had to update some of
those lyrics on Broadway to make them
less offensive
from The Music Man like what
well there was a song called Shipoopi
in it yeah that's like a legitimate song
poopy
the girl that's hard to get that's how
that song went
and then it would go but you can get her
yet and I can't remember what they
changed the lyrics to but it's like some
more socially Progressive thing so it's
probably you can't get her easy the girl
who's super smart or something like that
I don't know you know it's probably
something like that
well that's good is it good are you
happy with that when they I think it's
good when they update stuff do you think
they should update the Mona Lisa to make
it more socially Progressive should they
give her a nose ring and pink hair
no they need to put her with Like An
Egyptian headdress because they're the
people that started it all
what
the Egyptians
I'm kidding I don't know anything about
Egyptian people
do you
I know they had a revolution in Tahir
Square
at the Walmart there
yeah they were arguing for them to roll
back the prices
price rollbacks when is Walmart going to
start doing that again that's why
everybody used to shop there I haven't
seen that goddamn smiley face in ears I
know they stopped at the commercials
they're like we're getting way too much
hate mail
the YouTube comments are killing us
they're like we're just gonna go like
[ __ ]
something that doesn't have commercials
what company doesn't have commercials
Kmart doesn't anymore
Radio Shack doesn't have stores anymore
right now Blockbuster those are just
businesses that are out of business
there's a Blockbuster
there's a blockbuster there's one at
least one blockbuster though they get as
many commercials as there are stores
yeah missed Blockbuster commercials
I accidentally ran into a blockbuster
with my automobile
I think didn't are you serious I did
yeah that was when I first started
learning how to drive I didn't have my
license so I was trying to take a left
the building was here I was trying to
take a left
and then I realized it was a one-way so
I switched directions Midway but there
wasn't enough room so I hit it and all
the movies on that side of the wall fell
over are you serious yeah
that's funny I know it's crazy I was
just like on a wall who was in the car
with you anybody my mom and my sister
did they tell you to stop
they were mad at me did you have to go
back in there and clean up the uh no we
just dropped off the movie We're trying
to return and jetted I wonder what it
was do you remember that
uh like Homeward Bound or something
animal actors
yeah they can pay them less
tons less
did you know that Ike
I didn't and it troubles me you don't
think those actors put in just as much
work as say like a Daniel Day-Lewis type
no you don't think so you ever seen babe
I think it's mostly CG you ever seen
babe
I think uh the English Pig they wouldn't
know what what would they do with the
money they don't have a credit card
bigger pen better slop I don't know
that's not for me to decide
it's still called slop though
yeah it's just better better consistency
Charlotte's Web that was a sad movie
storing a pig
Animal Farm those animals are really
smart
probably would know to spend their money
on
slop
py
so what do you guys think about uh
eating the leftovers
I don't know don't eat the pizza it's
not been refrigerated yeah is there not
a fridge did you not put anything away
too big for the fridge you couldn't take
the stuff from last night in the fridge
what do you think about that crazy trip
that we take in the rain for no reason
that was fun that was actually a lot of
fun it was scary because it costs 150 I
was sorry
legitimately I was pretty scared some of
those uh lightning bolts were very close
to us it sounded like at least yes it
did we would have died I wasn't touching
any metal
but wouldn't it still shock you or would
it not it was just uncomfortable yeah it
would be a little shocking
I mean I think only the floor mats were
rubber but I mean what was the material
of the cushion the cushion didn't seem
that thick and we were all sitting on
like a giant metal framed electric
vehicle I don't know I don't know you
just gotta like put your hands in and
then let it go around you it's like a
faraday cage
Faraday cage Faraday cage what is that
is that like Nick Cage's dad
yeah Mike farida it's like a Easter egg
Easter Faberge fabergerac yeah deviled
um but uh yeah we it was really tricky
when we were at an intersection and then
the winds were like all funneled into
the intersection
yeah I heard and it came at you sideways
Hans was shivering like a little leaf in
in the in the wind it was yeah
oh man that's what happens when you get
poured on you look so like small and
well I was trying to get small no I was
trying to conserve body heat that's
smart you're huddling yeah gotcha I
wasn't going like this you could have
used me for warm ponds you could have
that ever happens again I'm just putting
that out there I was efficiently
conserving body heat by being a little
[ __ ]
no you weren't you had to do what you
had to do I know William was too nice so
he wasn't complaining and he was the
only other person on the right side so
my pants were soaked I got soaked by the
end I was soaked yeah it took a while
but I got there
I came in here and I turned up the heat
to 80 and then I forgot about it yeah it
was so hot in here
and we came back and it was 80.
back to 70. thank God 70's a little cold
for me I know even under blankets it's
cold I mean yeah because then you go to
the other side of the bed and then it's
like you gotta warm it up again why not
isn't that fun
it's something to do yeah I had to go to
like one side of the carpet to warm it
up I was like oh no this part of the rug
is way too chilly so I know what you
mean huh
well cold air Falls so it'd be even
colder on the floor than it is on the
bed so it's brutal it was brutal
warmir Rises
what are the meeting at 6 40.
what time is it 5 20. oh
okay what do you think I just said it
how long have we been on here I may lay
down and play balloons yeah hour and 20
minutes let's just read this
uh William looks like I kind of gotta
take my money to fix my car but ended up
making things horribly worse yeah no
[ __ ] it was me dumbass as much as 90 of
Asians are nearsighted in some regions
of the world okay okay we got a
scientist in the chat did you know after
Williams career in the CIA and I'm a
kind of French Foreign so uh well if we
had to say one thing
to the uh the legions of fans what would
you say
would you say like
um
pass pass
you would say pass pass I'll come okay
William what would you say pizza pizza
do you remember that Little Caesars yeah
because you get two pizzas the guy in
the little why don't stick companies do
that
I don't know is it in the same place
that the smiley face Walmart guy is
they're all about oh yeah in The Ether
somewhere yeah I think that little
Caesar guys still exists I'm pretty sure
he still is out there kicking
[ __ ] it up you know dude it's like a
Pokeball
Pokeball
how how so that's in The DaVinci Code
isn't it pokeballs isn't it
pokeballs yeah Da Vinci Code Pokey bowls
or Pokey balls what are you saying to me
pokeballs
never ask a Tennessee and to
yeah
don't don't talk to a Tennessee and if
you can help it isn't The Da Vinci Code
the one where he's on an island
yeah yeah that's the one where um it's
uh Mark Ruffalo and the whole Leonardo
and there's a painter I would say hey
guys achieve your dreams believe in
yourselves and
what else right right
um never stop
um rent always uh strive for the um
the stars because even if you miss uh
we're gonna land on the sun believe in
uh
dress for the job you want not the job
you never had yeah that's the that's
what I was gonna go with that's a good
one what if you've never had the job you
want you'll have to it's because you're
not you're dressing like [ __ ] that's why
yeah dress for the job you want not the
job you never had
[Laughter]
develop and blows
yeah when you were blowing me last night
I was thinking wow we're really becoming
friends I was so awkward you're blind me
so you get on a bed yeah I couldn't tell
which one was doing which I knew
something was happening on the floor oh
so when I'm doing it so sorry sorry when
I'm sucking your dick it's called me
blowing you right that's it okay gotcha
I got it mixed up we're all blowing each
other
yeah it's been fun I got blowed on today
by the wind of nature mother nature blew
me you too blew me away
you guys are good friends now
my mother
so um remember a lot I slept with his
daughter so it's okay to do that
lot begot two thoughts
would then be got more thoughts
that's something to think about it's
like green eggs and ham except two
daughters and spam
foreign
all right well uh we had a fun time
please don't report US
uh thank you you can report me